[Music]
all too well 10-minute version wins big
at the vmas and the vma goes too
[Music]
taking home video of the year taylor
saves the biggest prize for her swifties
i thought it might be a fun moment to
tell you
that my brand new album comes out
october 21st
this is not a drill new music from
taylor is on the way
[Applause]
yeah that's our reaction too lizzo
[Applause]
[Music]
posting on social media kayla confirms
her 10th studio album midnight
writing in part this is a collection of
music written in the middle of the night
a journey through terrors and sweet
dreams adding the stories of 13
sleepless nights scattered throughout my
life will be out october 21. meet me at
midnight
in addition miss swift becomes the first
artist to win video of the year for the
third time having one for bad blood and
you need to calm down
[Applause]
opening the show with a bang jack harlow
and fergie give us the collab we never
knew we needed and playing double duty
nicki minaj joined jack and ll cool j as
the evenings m.c
[Music]
it was a big night for the rapper who
performed the medley of hits before
receiving the mtv video vanguard award
the barbs
and of course there was a certain barb
who got a shout out while accepting her
second award of the night for best
hip-hop taylor swift who had a huge part
in the success of super bass
while the night continued with many
great performances and awards johnny
depp had heads turning with a surprise
appearance as the coveted moon man i
just want you guys to know that i'm
available for birthdays bar mitzvahs
[Music]
[Music]
taking the vma stage for the first time
blackpink performs their new single pink
venom
and the firsts don't stop there
blackpink member lisa becomes the first
k-pop soloist to win a vma
also making history kane brown he
becomes the first male country artist to
perform on the show
and nabbing the global icon award the
red hot chili peppers took a moment to
honor the late foo fighters drummer
taylor hawkins my brother taylor hawkins
[Music]
and i want to dedicate this to taylor
and his family i love them
and i miss him every day and uh fly on
hawk play on brother